APRIL FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING WE HAVE EIGHTY SEVEN
BILLS TO CONSIDER THIS MORNING-
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME
REALLY STRICT RULES I'D LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
AND ASSEMBLYWOMAN RADIUS FOR
COVERING VACANCIES ON THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. PARTY WILL
COME. WE'RE KEEPING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE BETWEEN ONE ANOTHER
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL WE ASK THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE IN THIS ROOM
YOU MUST WEAR A MASK AND KEEP
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SO. IF THAT
DOES NOT HAPPEN YOU WILL BE
REMOVED. WE ARE GOING TO
ACCEPT- PUBLIC TESTIMONY BY
PHONE. JUST I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR WHAT WORK SEVENTEEN. UP
TO TWO MINUTES IN SUPPORT FOR
TWO MINUTES IN OPPOSITION TO
ANY BILL. I NEVER MET YOUR
COMMENTS MUST BE FOCUSED ON THE
FISCAL POINT OF THE BILL. AFTER
THAT WE WILL SIMPLY TAKE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NOTHING MORE
NO. ADVERBS SNOW- WE KNOW IF
YOU SO YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE WILLING TO SUPPORT
SOMETHING WE KNOW YOU STRONGLY
SUPPORT SO WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT
AS- BRIEF AS POSSIBLE IN THAT
SECTION BECAUSE I AS I SAID
WE'VE EIGHTY SEVEN BILLS WE
COULD BE HERE ALL DAY AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO DO THAT. IF YOU
DISRUPT THE MEETING- ON THE
PHONE YOU WILL BE. TAKEN OFF
THE PHONE BY THE OPERATOR AND
MEDIA AT LEON. THIS IS. HOW WE
CONDUCT THIS SO THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE TRY TO
GET THROUGH ALL OF THESE- BILLS
DO WE HAVE WE DO HAVE A FORM
ALL RIGHT CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GONZALEZ BIGELOW
BONTA CALDERON CARRILLO CHAFF
DAWALY DAVIES FONG GABRIEL THEY
WERE GARCIA LEVINE QUIRK
ROBERT RIVAS MCCARTY RIESS.
THANK YOU N. I'M NOT SURE AT A
QUORUM IS PRESENT SO THANK YOU
AND WE WILL BEGAN. I USUALLY
HAVE A SIGN IN SHEET BUT I SEE
THAT MISTER BURN A **** BATH
WAS THE FIRST PERSON AND SO WE
WILL TAKE HER I WILL TAKE
AUTHORS AS THEY COME ON TRY TO
PAY ATTENTION- MISPRINT HOW OR
BATH. YOU'RE PRESENTING AB ONE
TWO TWO IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB ONE TWENTY TWO WOULD
MAKE INTERSECTIONS SAFER FOR
BICYCLISTS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS BY ALLOWING
BICYCLISTS TO TREAT STOP SIGNS.
AS YIELD SIGNS WHEN APPROACHING
THE INTERSECTION WELL THIS IS
CHARACTER COUNTER INTUITIVE.
THE DATA OUT OF DELAWARE SHOWN
THAT THERE'S A TWENTY SIX
PROJECT PERCENT REDUCTION AND
CARPI SICKLE COLLISIONS- WHEN
YOU HAVE BICYCLISTS BE ABLE TO
STOP AS YOU. BECAUSE IT MAKES
BICYCLUS FOR- BEHAVIOR
PREDICTABLE FOR DRIVERS AND SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
HAVE A WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER RIVAS WE'VE A SECOND BY
MISS RADIUS- DO YOU HAVE. IT
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE THE-
PRESENTATION OF A SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT. GIVE A WETNESS NOT ON
THE AGENDA. I'M GLAD YOU HAVE
THE AGENDA- SO WHAT THERE IS NO
WITNESS WERE YOU EXPECTING
WITNESS MISS BOERNER HORVATH
THANK YOU- SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT-
IS THEIR WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
WHAT ALL RIGHT I HEAR NINE WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION STARTING WITH YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION ON AB. ONE TWO TWO.
MISTER OPERATOR. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START FROM THE PHONES. YES I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IS JUST
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON AB ONE TWENTY TWO
BOERNER HORVATH. THANK YOU TO
STATE YOUR POSITION ON AB ONE
TWO TO ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONCE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE DO HAVE A FEW LINES IN
KEANE'S ME JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
WHAT ALAINA LEVIN ONE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FINAL. M. I. LINE
ELEVEN YOU ARE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HOW ARE YOU- I'M CALLING
APPROPRIATIONS THE MY IN THE
RIGHT PLACE. WE ARE ONLY TAKING
THAT THE ISSE OF SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE OF THIS BILL AND YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. M. I. N.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THIS
IS THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES OH OH GOOD
OKAY AT WORK BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS WORK- AND I'M CALLING
ABOUT. EIGHTY FIVE. RIGHT CAN
YOU PLEASE HANG THIS PHONE UP.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE TWENTY
THREE. TWO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU AMANDA CALDERON
THAT TRIPLE A OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU DON'T GO
OVER NINE TWENTY NINE TWO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND IF
THERE'S A CULTURE FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NO FOR THE
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU AND THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. LOW WONDERFUL THAT. GET
OUT OF B. ROLL CALL. I SEE WITH
BIGELOW NOT PUTTING THEIR IT IS.
THANK YOU SORRY SORRY WE'RE A
LITTLE RUSTY HERE. DID I SEE MR
CHAN. AB. FIVE FIFTEEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW IN A SECOND
BY MISS RAYOS- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IN THE LIEU OF TIME- ALL
HOME THE HOUSE FOR A VOTE. WE
DO HAVE A WITNESS MISTER TV
AIRS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED REPRESENTS FOR ONLINE
WILL MANAGER THANK YOU OPERATOR
CAN YOU GO TO MISTER G. AT G.
V. AIRS. THE WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY FIVE FIFTEEN THE LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS G. V. AIRS
WITHIN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LICENSED THREE POSSESSORS-
WE ARE SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND
IN SUPPORT- HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU OPERATOR
CAN YOU NOW TAKE SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION ON AB FIVE FIFTEEN
FROM THE PHONE LINES. THANK
THANK YOU TO EXPRESS YOUR
POSITION ON AB FIVE FIFTEEN ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN THIS IS FOR AB FIVE ONE
FIVE WE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE ONE LINE IN
Q. WITH LINE ELEVEN. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ALL RIGHT- I THINK
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES IN APPROPRIATIONS
AND TRYING TO SPEAK ON FIVE ONE
FIVE. IT MIGHT BE MAYBE IS THIS
FIVE MINUTE RETAIN ON FIVE ONE
FIVE. I'M SPEAKING YES I'M FIVE
ONE FIVE AND I'M OPPOSED TO
FIVE ONE FIVE. THANK YOU YOUR
NAME PLEASE. MY NAME IS ANDREA
STRUM I WENT YESTERDAY DO YOU
WE THANK YOU CAN NOW THANK YOU
THIS HEDSTROM WE ALWAYS
APPRECIATE HEARING FROM YOU. M.
WITH THAT WE WILL BRING IT BACK
I SEE NO COMMENTS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MR CHAN I ONLY
AUTHORIZED THE. CHECK IT OUT ON
A ROLL CALL AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU MISTER TENDER'S GAVE MASTER
CLASS IN HOW TO PRESENT A BILL
APPROPRIATIONS SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU MANAGER FOR TIME. ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT I SEE NOW-
AUTHORS. WAITING WE WOULD LIKE
TO. GET SOMEBODY DOWN HERE IF
NOT WE WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
WE WILL START TO GET THE
COMMITTEE- MISS DAVIES YOU'RE
PRESENTING AB TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN. THIS IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WHEREVER YOU
WANT WE'RE GOOD AT A MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW IN A SECOND BY
MISS RADIUS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN IS A MEASURE THAT
REQUIRES THE APPLICATION FOR
CALIFORNIA SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM
THE JUDICIARY COUNCIL FORM
RELATED TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS TO BE
AVAILABLE IN THE FIVE MOST
SPOKEN LANGUAGES IN CALIFORNIA
OTHER THAN ENGLISH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT ON
AB TWO SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR- CAN WE TAKE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN. YOU STATE
YOUR POSITION ON AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE'LL GO TO
LINE ELEVEN ONE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN- WORKING- PLEASE IS
ANDREA SOMEBODY CAN'T. OPERATE
ONE OF THE. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WITHOUT THAT GETS OUT ANI-
A ROLL CALL THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WHY DON'T WE TAKE A
MOMENT BEFORE WE GO TO MR FONG
AND GO AHEAD AND TAKE A MOTION
ON THE CONFECTION WONDER FIRST
WE READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WITH THE CONSENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CLOSE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR MISS REYES SECOND.
OKAY COMMITTEE ON THE VINYL
SAFETY IN TALKS WITH CEREALS AB
THREE THREE TWO COMMITTEE ON
RENTAL SAFETY AND TALK TO GET
HEROES AB SIX NINE EIGHT THREE
ON HEALTH AB EIGHT THREE ONE
ARAMBULA A. B. FOUR FIVE ONE
ARAMBULA SIX NINE ZERO BIGELOW
AB FOUR FOUR ZERO CHAO AC OR
TWENTY FOUR COOPER AB THREE
FIVE NINE DOLLARS A AB FOUR TWO
NINE THE DAVIES AB THREE EIGHT
ONE. DAVIES AB FOR- CZ FIVE
FOUR THREE GALLAGHER AB TWO
THREE TWO GRAY AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SIX GRAYSON AB FIVE SIX
NINE IRWIN AB NINE ONE FOUR
COMMAGER AB THREE EIGHT TWO
BLACKIE AB THIRTEEN OH FIVE
LEVINE AB EIGHT ONE NINE LOW AB
SEVENTY THREE MAIENSCHEIN A. B.
EIGHT FIVE SIX MCCARTY AB FIVE
OH FOUR MULLIN AB FIVE THREE
FOUR THREE FIVE. THE WIN A. B.
TEN THIRTY NINE. PATTERSON
EIGHTY FOUR THREE ONE QUIRK AB
TWO FOUR SIX. CORK AB THREE OH
FOUR QUIRK AB SEVENTY FOUR
QUICK SILVA AB SIX THREE EIGHT
VIAPADUKA AB FIVE NINE ONE
WALDRON SB SIX SIX TWO SEVEN
WOOD AB FIVE THREE TWO. THANK
YOU AS A CONTENT CALENDAR GETS
OUT ON ANY ROLE. WITH THAT WE
STILL SEE NOW ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS TO WILL GO TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MR FONG IF YOU CAN
START WITH AB THREE. A BIG
CHAIR MEMBERS AB THREE AIMS TO
CURB ILLEGAL STREET RACING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I SEE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW IN A
SECOND BY MISTER ALI- WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONES IS THERE.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE. TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR AB THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BEGINNING ME USER TELEPHONE TO
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY THREE
TO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
AMANDA WATER ON MY WITH TRIPLE
A AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM LINE EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TWENTY.
MEMBERS RIGHT UP ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- FOR NO
FOR THE LINES INTO IT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS- MR FONG THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. WE WILL
MOVE NOW I'M GOING TO HOLD YOUR
NEXT PRESENTATION BECAUSE WE
HAVE AUTHORS IN THE ROOM WE'LL
START WITH MR ROOM. RAMOS WHO
WAS- HERE FIRST SORRY MR
BERMAN- MISTER THOMAS CAN
PRESENT ON AB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I SEE A OUR MOTION BY MISS
RAYOS AND ANY- SECOND BY MISTER
RIVAS MR ALMOST. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE-
COMMITTEE ON THE MOTION THE
SECOND- I INTRODUCED AB FIFTY
FIVE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. IT WOULD
ESTABLISH CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN DAY AS A PAID HOLIDAY
FOR CALIFORNIA COURTS WITHOUT
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF PAID
COURT HOLIDAYS. JUDICIAL
COUNCIL EMPLOYEES ARE COVERED
UNDER A SEPARATE CODE SECTION.
IN OTHER STATE WORKERS
THEREFORE THIS IS EXCLUSIVE TO
THEM. CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN DAY IS ALREADY A STATE
HOLIDAY. I LOBBIED IT IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WITH AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE BACA. BUT
IT'S AN UNPAID HOLIDAY AND WHAT
THE JUDICIAL COURTS IS DOING IS
EXCHANGING HER COLUMBUS DAY.
AND CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY FOR THE PAID HOLIDAY. AND
FOR MANY TOWARDS MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS I HAVE WORKED
TOWARDS CREATING A PAID STATE
HOLIDAY TO RECOGNIZE AND LEARN
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE.
CONTINUING TO WORK TO EDUCATE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
WITH HOW HELP TO MOVE THAT
FORWARD WHEN A ONE EXAMPLE IS
MANY OF THE HIGHWAYS THAT WE
TRAVEL OR ONCE INDIAN TRAILS
AND NOW WE TRAVEL THOSE ROADS.
IN MY AREA AND REDLANDS THE
INDIAN PEOPLE SERRANO CAREER
GABRIELLE PEOPLE HELP TO DIG
DESIGN OTHER BROUGHT WATER INTO
RESIDENTS THAT HAVE THAT
COMMUNITY FLOURISH. WITH ME
TODAY AS A WITNESS I HAVE KßT
NHTSA OF THE GOVERNMENTAL FARE.
FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MR ALMOST
OPERATOR CAN YOU PUT KATE NEED
A ON THE PHONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS HE HAD WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE HOUSE EXPOSITOR
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE FIVE AND
WHILE THERE WILL BE SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK TO-
TRANSITION BE JUDICIAL HOLIDAY
FROM COLUMBUS DAY TO THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
THE BRANCH ESTIMATES THAT THIS
WILL HAVE NO PRACTICAL IMPACT
IN YOUR HAPPY BE IMPLEMENTED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB. EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE. I'M SURE THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU AM I
JUST REALIZED THAT I HAVE NOT
BEEN GOING TO THE APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THEY'RE NOT HERE-
THEY'RE NOT HERE WE DON'T HAVE
TO GO TO THEM OKAY. THAT'S GOOD
TO HEAR. THAT I SEE NO COMMENTS
IN THE GLLERY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE BURKE YOUR MANAGER AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ANTI
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
YOU GOT IT YOU'RE OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MISTER ALMOST
THANK YOU. NEXT MAY MR BERMAN-
MR BERMAN IS PRESENTING ON A.
B. TEN TEN. IT. IT HAS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE AN
BY MISS RADIUS I WAS SECOND BY
MISTAKE HE'S THIS IS A VERY
GOOD BILL THAT THAT I THOUGHT
MY TO SNACK ON CONSENT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU AND WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TEN TEN. BUT TAKE A POSITION IN
AB TEN TEN WE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE 12-1 TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M SURE MEMBERS MICHAEL OAK
FOR THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIA- WE'RE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL NET ZERO CARBON IS THE
DESIGN ISSUE OF OUR TIME IT
WILL HELP REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. BUT HAVE ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS IN ENERGY CONSERVATION
AND EVEN WILDFIRE ISSUES SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY LOW
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT FOR ARCHITECTS THIS
IS A VERY MODEST INCREASE. AND
WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I THOUGHT.
AS SNAPPLE WITNESS AND THEY'RE
NOW WILL GO TO THE PHONES ANY
OTHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
JUST NAME POSITION ANNA.
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE. ONE
DO YOU KNOW THE LINES INTO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU I SEE NO
COMMENTS FROM. THE COMMITTEE MR
BERMAN THIS PROFESSOR I WROTE
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR BIGELOW NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON. I SEE OUR YEARLY
DECISION TO. PRESENT ON A
SUSPENSE BILL SO THIS IS A
SUSPENSEFUL WE WON'T TAKE A
MOTION ON IT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN ON AB TWO SIXTY TWO YES
UP. YET MANAGER MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED THE A. B. TWO SIX TWO
WHICH WILL SIMPLIFY AND
EXPEDITE. THE PROCESS FOR
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
BEGIN TO HAVE THEIR RECORDS
CLEARED ALSO KNOWN AS THEY GET
YOUR RELIEF. CURRENT LAW
CREATES A CATCH TWENTY TWO THAT
MAKES IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR
SURVIVORS TO CLEAR THEIR
CRIMINAL. RECORD SURVIVORS
OFTEN HAVE TO PAY ALL FINES
BEETLE PROBATION REQUIREMENTS
BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN ASK A
COURT TO CLEAR THEIR CRIMINAL
RECORD OF NONVIOLENT. OFFENSES
WITHOUT A- CLEAR- RECORD
EMPLOYMENT IS NEXT TO
IMPOSSIBLE WITHOUT EMPLOYMENT
PAYING A FEE TO THE COURT AS A
BARRIER THAT PREVENTS MANY
SURVIVORS. FROM EVEN TRYING TO
CLEAR THEIR RECORDS SO THE BILL
WOULD PREVENT A COURT FROM
REFUSING TO HEAR A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS PETITION-
FOR REC. RECORD CLEARANCE DUE
TO UNPAID FINES OR FEES IT ALSO
WOULD GIVE SURVIVORS THE
ABILITY TO PETITION FOR
VACATION RELIEF AT ANYTIME
AFTER THEY ARE REMOVED. FROM
TRAFFICKING CURRENT LAW HIS
AMBIGUOUS AS TO HOW MUCH TIME-
PAST IS REASONABLE. AB TWO SIX
TWO IS SEEKING A CLEARER PATH
WITH MORE CERTAINTY. FOR
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
I THANK YOU A HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL. IS- ARI AND
PAUL'S. OPERATOR CAN YOU LET
THE WITNESS ARE YOU INVOLVED
SPEAK. THANK YOU MELENDEZ OF.
AND HIGHER AND I'M NOT AND MY
NAME IS ARE YOU CLOSE I AM A
SURVIVOR OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHEN I FIRST PICKED STATE MY
TRACKING SITUATION THE ONE
THING I WANTED MORE THAN
ANYTHING WHAT THE GAIN
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT SIDELIGHT
AT EVERY MCDONALD'S IN THE
FRESNO CLOVIS. I EVEN TOOK A
JOB INTERVIEW. AT A STEP WAY
OUT TOLD I WOULD BACK AFTER
THEY DID MY BACKGROUND CHECKS.
I NEVER HEARD BACK I FIGURED I
WOULD MAYBE HAVE A BETTER
CHANCE. IF I HAD A
CERTIFICATION OR SOMETHING MY
NAME SO I AM QUITE- AND GOT
INTO. INDIAN PEOPLE WHERE I
GRADUATED TOP OF MY CLASS AND
GOT NATIONALLY CERTIFIED. I
THINK OUR NOW SURELY I'D BE
ABLE TO GET A JOB. SO WHEN IT.
SO WHEN I WENT. HI IT WAS A
VERY DEVASTATING BLOW WHEN THE
COUNTY TOLD ME I WAS. DUE TO MY
CRIMINAL RECORD. IN THAT MOMENT
I KNOW EXACTLY WHY COOLEY
VICTIMS LIKE MYSELF. WOULD END
UP. AND GO BACK TO THE STREET.
THIS BILL WOULD BE EXTREMELY
BENEFICIAL TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SURVIVOR TO WORKING TO A BETTER
LIFE SHE- BILL AB TWO. SIX YOU
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE WHEN I STATE
I NEVER WOULD HAVE PLAYED AN
INSTRUMENTAL PART IN MY ROAD
HEALING AND RESTORATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE ANY WITNESS.
AND OPPOSITE. I DON'T THINK
THERE IS WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
AB TWO SIXTY TWO. OPERATOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO STATE
YOUR POSITION IN AB TWO SIX TWO
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WHAT A LINE. THIRTY EIGHT THREE
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT WILL NINE FORTY SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I
DON'T BELIEVE PUBLIC COMMENT
WAS TAKEN ON AB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE I WAS HOLDING TO SPEAK ON
AB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE AND I DON'T
BELIEVE PUBLIC COMMENT WAS
TAKEN WE DID TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU. THERE WAS NO
BODY IN THE QUEUE. IN ORDER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- MISTER PATTERSON THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED TO SUSPEND
SAID. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AND OF HOPE THAT- WHEN
YOU CONSIDER- BUT- THEY-
SUSPENSE FILE- THAT- YOU LOOK
FAVORABLY UPON THE BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I'M WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I SEE NOBODY
PRESENT- JUST TO BE CLEAR WERE
LOOKING FOR THREE OF US- BUFFY
WICKS OH NO MISTER CORK IS
GOING TO PRESENT ON HER BEHALF
IN MR CHILL. M. WE'LL GO BACK
TO MR FONG WHO IS GOING TO
PRESENT ON- MISFIRED AT US-
BILL. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
AB THIRTY SIX SEVEN AS A
NECESSARY MEASURE THAT WILL
CONTINUE STREAMLINING WILDFIRE
PREVENTION PROJECTS I STRICTLY
ASPEN EITHER. I HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER BIGELOW A SECOND BY
MISS DOLLY- WE WILL GO TO ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THIS IS
AB. TWO SIX SEVEN. DO WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. BUT NONE
SCHEDULED WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN AT THE PUBLIC COMMENT SURE.
IF YOU LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR
POSITION ON AB TWO SIX SEVEN
NEWMAN PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE NINE ZERO. LEARN
ONLINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE
WILL BRING IT BACK THERE'S NO
DISCUSSION I'M- THAT GETS OUT
ON AN A ROLL CALL WITH MISS
REYES IN THE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
MOVING ON- OKAY I THINK WE ONE
MORE COMMITTEE MEMBER HAS BUILT
INTO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESENTING ON BILLS. MISTER
REVERSE. AB TWO SEVENTY WANTED
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I SEE A MOTION BY MISS RAYOS A
SECOND BY MISTAKE THESE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR BILLS A AMENDED
RERUN FROM LAST YEAR FISCAL
IMPACT IS MINOR AND ABSORB ALL
RESPECT THAT'S WHEN I VOTE I
ALSO I WILL BE DOING A
PRESENTATION FOR SOMETHING.
WOMAN THREE OF US. GOOD TO
KNOW- ON MYSTERY THIS IS BILL
AB TWO SEVENTY ONE WE I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IF SO CAN WE OPEN UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
POSITION ON A B. TWO SEVEN ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE DO HAVE A COMMON NAME
KEY ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THE LINE
FORTY NINE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS JACK
BUILT IN YOUR CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NO OTHER LINE CAN
KEEP. THANK YOU AND MYSTERY
VESTS THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL YOU'RE NOW GOING TO
PRESENT FOR THAT MYSTERY OF US
AB THREE TWENTY SIX. SOME
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US- THISLEGISLATION
REMOVES A SUNSET DATE ON THE
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE OR THE M. H. C.
AFTER ALMOST TO- SOME DECADES
IN EXISTENCE THE CONSUMER
PROGRAM IS NO LONGER NEW AND
EXPERIMENTAL. BUT RATHER A
WELL- DEMONSTRATED IN
SUCCESSFUL TOOL FOR PROVIDING
CONSUMERS AN IMPORTANT ADVOCATE
IN THEIR CORNER I HAD AMASSED A
MASSIVE I THINK OUR MOTION BY
MISS RAYOS A SECOND BY MISS
CALDERON AND WE WILL TAKE THIS
TO THE PHONES AB THREE TWENTY
SIX. YOU STATE YOUR POSITION ON
AB THREE TWENTY SIX NGUYEN
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
THAT IS ONE OF THEM ZERO.
BLOODLINE FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PROUD SPONSOR AND
SUPPORTER. THANK YOU. LINE
FORTY THREE FOUR THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
RONALD KOEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK WE'RE HERE TO SPONSOR
AN INSTRUCTOR IN STRONG UPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY SIX FOUR SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR JOSE TORRES WITH
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA OUT.
THOUGH AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NO FURTHER ALIGNED
IN Q. THANK YOU I SEE NO
QUESTIONS- THAT HAS A MOTION
AND A SECOND BUT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO PUT THAT ON CALL
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH.
FOLKS- DEMOCRATS IN THE ROOM SO
IF MR KEVIN MCCARTY OR MR
EDUARDO GARCIA OR MISTER ROB
BONTA IS IN THE BUILDING AND
CAN PLEASE COME TO COMMITTEE.
WELL OR MISS WENDY CARILLO WHO
I KNOW WAS PRESENTING ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO IF WE COULD GET
ANY OF THOSE MEMBERS WE JUST
NEED ONE OF THEM TO COME. TO
HE FLOOR WE CAN GET YOUR
COLLEAGUES BILLS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. WITH THAT- JUST IN
TIME THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL THANK YOU. IT WAS MAGIC MR
GARCIA MAGIC. WE WILL NOW MOVE-
TO MISS WICKS BUILD BEING
PRESENTED BY MISTER DOCTOR
QUIRK AB FIVE EIGHTEEN- ENJOY
ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER CALDERON A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO. YOU MAY PRESENT.
FIVE ONE EIGHT RESTORE A
JUDGE'S DISCRETION DETERMINE
THE SENTENCE THAT BEST FITS THE
CRIME WHEN A PERSON IS ACCUSED
OF MULTIPLE OFFENSES DURING A
SINGLE ACT. BY RESTORING-
JUDGES ABILITY TO GIVE
APPROPRIATE SENATORS READ THE
LONGEST POSSIBLE POTENTIAL TERM
OF IMPRISONMENT IN THESE CASES.
CDC ARE AND LOCAL JAILS ROUTINE
KERR SERRATION COSTS REDUCED IS
INDIVIDUAL SPEND LESS TIME
SERVING EXCESSIVE SENTENCES I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU WE I DON'T SEE THAT WE HAVE
WITNESSES BUT WE'LL GO THE
PHONES FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE EIGHTEEN.
STATE POSITION ON AB FIVE
TWENTY ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD IT'S ONE OF
THEM ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU OUT ON A
B. ROAD CALL. OUR OUR LAB BILL
HAS OF THE DAY IS. MISTER
CHOOSE AB TWO FORTY FIVE PM
PRESENTED BY MR GABRIEL. I HAVE
A MOTION BY MISS RAY IS THE
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AB TWO
FOUR FIVE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHERO TRANSGENDER AND
NON BINARY STUDENTS FACE MANY
BARRIERS AT SCHOOL AND IN THE
WORKPLACE. BEING DEAD NAMES ON
THEIR COLLEGE DIPLOMA OR
TRANSCRIPT SHOULD NOT BE
ANOTHER HURDLE THEY HAVE TO
FACE. PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THEIR STERN RECORDS AND
THE RECORD SHOULD HAVE THE
CORRECT NAME ON THEM THAT IS
WHAT THIS BILL DOES WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK MR GABRIEL WILL I
SEE NO- WITNESSES BUT WILL OPEN
UP TO THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
FORTY FIVE. TO STATE YOUR
POSITION ON AB TWO FORTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. LOCAL FIRST
ONLINE THIRTY THREE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA SPONSORED THE BILL
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER LINE IN Q. I APOLOGIZE
OF THE ANOTHER MOMENT THAT'S
OKAY. BORDERLINE FORTY FIVE
FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL THIS IS JENNIFER GONZALEZ
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LET ME GO
LOCKET IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FOUR FIVE. THANK YOU. NO
FOR THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
AND I SEE NO QUESTIONS IN THE
GALLERY SO THAT AB TWO FORTY
FIVE GETS OUT WITH ON A GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS ABSTAINING.
YES THAT COMPLETES OUR BILL
PRESENTATIONS AT THIS POINT
WILL READ- THE LIST OF BILLS
THAT ARE BEING MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE CALENDAR AND THE
AUTHORS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION. MISTER CLIP.
AGUIAR-CURRY. AB TEN EIGHT SIX
BENNETT'S A SEVEN ONE SIX A SO
SEVEN Y. BENNETT A EIGHT SIX
BOERNER HORVATH EIGHTY SIX SIX
BONTA AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
CARILLO AB FIVE SEVEN THREE
CHEN AB THREE OH EIGHT. DAHLE
A. AB FIVE ONE SIX FLOOR AB TWO
SEVEN EIGHT GABRIEL AB FIVE
SEVEN ATWATER CA AB ONE TWO SIX
GIPSON AB THREE FOUR TWO HOLDEN
AB TWENTY SIX HOLDEN AB ONE
HUNDRED HOLDEN AB TWO EIGHT
FIVE JONES SAWYER AB THREE
THREE ONE JONES SAWYER AB FOUR
EIGHT THREE. KALRA AB. TWO FIVE
SIX KALRA AB FOUR THREE SEVEN
LACKEY AB EIGHT LACKEY AB THREE
NINE FIVE LEVINE AB EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN LEVINE AB NINE THREE
ZERO. MAIENSCHEIN AB FIVE SEVEN
SIX MCCARTY AB FOUR ONE SEVEN
MCCARTY AB FIVE FOUR SEVEN
MCCARTY B. FIVE NINE FOUR
MEDINA AB THREE SEVEN FIVE
MEDINA AB THREE EIGHT EIGHT.
O'DONNELL AB FIVE FOUR FOUR
PATTERSON AB TWO SIX TWO
PETRIE-NORRIS AB TWO SIX FIVE
QUIRK SILVA AB. THREE FOUR FIVE
RAMOS AB TWO THREE FOUR
THREE OF US AB FIVE EIGHT FIVE
THREE OF US EIGHTY EIGHT ONE
FIVE THREE OF US EIGHTY NINE
SEVEN SIX RODRIGUEZ AB TWO
FORTY. SAY AUTO AB THREE ONE
TWO STONE AB TWO NINE TWO TíNH
AB TWELVE OH EIGHT WALDRON
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY TWO WARD AB
THREE FORTY AND WARD AB FORTY
ONE. THANK YOU FOR THOSE WHO
MAY HAVE WANTED TO COMMENT ON
THOSE BILLS THE AUTHORS HAVE
WAVE PRESENTATION SO WHAT WE'LL
DO NOW IS WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY
OF THOSE BILLS BUT ALL YOU CAN
SAY IS YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND SUPPORT OR OPPOSE IN THE
BILL NUMBER THAT IS ALL WE ARE
TAKING. AT THIS TIME MR
OPERATOR. YOU JUST STEPPED OUT
YOUR POSITION ON ONE OR SEVERAL
GOALS BILLS ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. DOES ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO SOMEONE Q. JUST A MOMENT.
BUT OUR FIRST LINE TWENTY ONE
TO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
HAVE BEEN IN A NUMBER OF PAIN
AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AND WE SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU. OVER THE LINE TWENTY
THREE TO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MARIA JOHNSON WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY SEVEN FOUR SEVEN. HI LINE.
FORTY SEVEN- MY NAME IS ANDREA
HAD STRONG. AND I'M AGAINST A
NUMBER OF THOSE BILLS SHOULD I
JUST KIND OF START LISTING
THOSE ALL. AND I'M ACTUALLY FOR
A NUMBER OF THE BILLS THAT IS
LINE LET'S START WITH THE
OPPOSITION PLEASE LISTEN I'M
THE BILLS THAT YOU'RE OPPOSED
TO. WELL I'M OPPOSED TO AB. ONE
L. EIGHT SIX AGUIAR-CURRY. AND
I'M OPPOSED TO AB NUMBER. FOUR
FIVE ONE. AND I'M OPPOSED TO AB
NUMBER. SIX SEVEN SIX NINE
ZERO. HELLO POSTAVY SEVEN ONE
SEX. I'M OPPOSED AB NUMBER
SEVEN SEVEN ONE I'M OPPOSED TO
EIGHT THE NUMBER. EIGHT NINE
SIX. I'M OPPOSED AB ONE OH ONE
NOW. ONE IS PRETTY GOOD IF YOU
GET A PRESENT AB FOUR FOUR ZERO
I DIDN'T HEAR THAT ONE ON THE
LEFT ARE ONLY TAKING ABOUT YOUR
YOU CAN STATE THE BILLS HERE
OPPOSED TO WE CAN MOVE ON TO
THE BILL'S YOUR SUPPORT OF BUT
WE ARE NOT TAKING ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION. HI I JUST WANTED A
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I MEAN I
DON'T. I MEAN TO A BILL THAT
I'M- SUPPORT OF. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO LIST THE BILL'S YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF NOW. HOLDERS ONE I
AM SUPPORTIVE BUT THEN CAN I GO
BACK TO THE ONES I'M AGAINST-
WE ARE GOING TO FINISH THIS
CONVERSATION IF YOU CANNOT
FOLLOW THE RULES OF SIMPLY
SAYING SUPPORT OR OPPOSE IN THE
BILL NUMBER AND THAT IS THE
ONLY TESTIMONY WERE TAKING. NO
ANCILLARY DISCUSSION AND IF YOU
CANNOT FOLLOW THAT BASICALLY.
HAVE TO DISCONNECT YOU. OKAY
I'LL KEEP GOING. ONCE AGAINST
AB NUMBER SIXTY SIX I'M AGAINST
AB NUMBER. ONE TWENTY TWO. I'M
AGAINST AB NUMBER. TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT- I'M AGAINST- COOPER
DEFINITELY I'M AGAINST COOPER
AB THREE FIFTY NINE- WOW IT'S
QUITE A LIST OKAY YEAH AGAIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
HEDSTROM YOU'VE NEVER CONTROLS
THREE TIMES SO WE'RE GOING TO
DISCONNECT YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SUBMIT YOUR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION BY- LETTER WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THAT BY THE
COMMITTEE. MR PRINTER YOU CAN
MOVE ON. OR LINE TWENTY EIGHT
TO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
DAVID AS A VETO WITH A RP
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE EIGHT FIVE. THANK YOU OKAY.
NINE FIFTEEN ONE FIVE. HI
JULIAN INDO ON BEHALF OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. FIVE SEVENTY THREE. THE
BOTTOM LINE TWENTY FIVE TO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
MAGGIE CALLING WITH A
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
THAT WOULD BE TWENTY THANK.
LINE FIFTY TWO FIVE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ADAM CHAIR TONY
TOOKE ERRO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO EIGHT FIVE
HOLDEN AND AB FIVE FOUR FOUR
O'DONNELL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE TWENTY SIX TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY SIX.
WILL MOVE ON THE LINE FORTY
EIGHT FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. COLOR ONLINE FORTY EIGHT.
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE ON YOUR OWN
DEVICE. THANK YOU AND YET THEY
ARE NOT WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO THREE FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE FIFTY THREE FIVE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TODD BLOOM STEIN
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION I IN
SUPPORT AND SPONSORING EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY BY MR LEVINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.LINE FIFTY FOUR
FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
NOT AVAILABLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AT COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR ONE SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN TWENTY
TWO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
TWENTY IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE.
HI SIGN IN VIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES AND
ALL OF A CALIFORNIA ACCESS
COALITION AND WE SUPPORT AB.
TWO THREE FOUR. IN OUR FINAL
LINING CUES LINE FIFTY FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI
LYDIA ONE WOULD CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF. AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE ALSO- A.
B. TWO FOUR ZERO ALONG WITH THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
THANK YOU. AND THAT CONCLUDES
PUBLIC COMMENT MR PRATER. BUT
WE'VE HAD TO TWO LINES
ADDITIONALLY COME TO THE
MICROPHONE OKAY LET'S TRY THOSE.
CONNEXT ONLINE. THEY CAN'T HEAR
ME RIGHT NOW. ONE FIFTY SIX
FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS THE FACT
THAT STEM THE CHAIR OF THE
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS NETWORK
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE SUPPORT
AB ONE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IN LINE FORTY TWO
FOUR TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ACTION CALLED REPRESENTING
CHOICE MEDICAL GROUP I
COSPONSORED THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION- AB THREE
FIVE NINE BY SOME OF THE
COOPER. AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY EIGHT ONE FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REQUEST THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THE STAFF WRITER IS THAT
COMPLETE. IT DOES COMPLETE THE
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU YOU ARE FABULOUS- FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE TODAY ABSOLUTELY
FABULOUS M. WITH THAT WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IF SOMEBODY FEELS
LIKE THEY NEED TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
BILLS- THAT ARE ON SUSPENSE
AND- COULDN'T GET THROUGH IT.
ADEQUATELY ON THE PHONE TODAY-
THEY ARE WELCOME TO SUBMIT
THOSE TO THE COMMITTEE IN
WRITING THANK YOU AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PREPARATION
COMMITTEE.